instead of a hand off it is a handshake
between sales and customer success and
so the point here is that the moment
they close the moment the card goes
through they're going to have immediate
remorse and so our goal is to totally
reinforce the decision personalize video
from the next person be like hey and
this is an important point from an
operational standpoint it's like hey I
heard you're trying to retire a wife I
think that's amazing I hear they were
trying to get to ten thousand dollars a
month I think you're going to blow that
away You're gonna do such a good job so
just to give you a heads up tomorrow
it's me Tammy forgot to introduce myself
and we're going to be walking through
XYZ so that we can help you get your
your wife retired as fast as possible
cool really excited to see you I sent
you an email with all the details too
see you tomorrow right and so now
they're like okay this is a legit
company I just got you know I've just
got off the phone you know the phone
thing and an hour later I get this thing
I'm like okay this is cool I feel good
about this decision and that's what we
want them to think I feel good about
this decision and we're like great and
then it decreases the cold feet and
walkouts and backups